Hey, everyone, we are in chapter five, and we are going to be taking a look at some questions and how we would answer those questions.
Again, these are related to how you could possibly see things like these kind of questions on your quizzes or your exams.
And these do, again, align with our learning objectives.
So let's go ahead and dive into it with question number one.
Here we are promised $1,500 in two years.
If the discount rate is 10%, what is the present value of that future payment?
Okay, so our present value is defined as PV is equal to the AM that we're going to get.
So let's put $1,500 here over one, plus whatever the interest rate happens to be.
In this case, it's 10%.
And keep in mind, we're going to have two years of, hey, this is going to take place in two years.
So our exponent there is going to be raised to the two.
So all we need to do is just rewrite this equation.
1500 over 1.1 raised to the 2, and then solve that out.  And I'm going to do this.
I'm going to pull it in my little my Excel file here or Excel sheet, and I'm going to go ahead and solve this out.
But I need to put a.
Let's do parentheses there.
I guess I really don't need to raise 2.
And we get 1239.67.
So we can see that D is going to be our answer.
Now, we could have looked at this as a compounding formula instead.
So if this asks us for compounding, what would $1,500 be two years from now, Then we would say the future value is going to be 1500 times 1.1.
Raise that to the two.
So now instead of dividing, I'm going to find I'm going to multiply.
So let's multiply that.
And I get.  I used X as opposed to a times.  There we go.
And we get 1815.
So had I asked for compounding instead of present value, so compounding instead of discounting, then 1815 would have been my answer.
But I asked for present value.
So that means that we're using discounting because we're trying to figure out, what is this right here?
What is that worth at 10% two years from now?
We can clearly see that it's $1,500.
Let's move on to our next question.
A project requires an upfront investment of $10,000.
It returns 4,000 per year for three years.
If the firm's cost of capital is 10% should that firm invest?
So this is a net present value question.
And so what we're looking at is the net present value is going to be the stream of payments that we receive minus the initial upfront investment.
So in this case, we're going to have 4,000 is what we receive per year.
We're going to have a.
What is our cost per capita here?  10%.
So let's put 1.1.
Now, net present value.
Deal with three years.
So our exponents change.
And this is going to be one there.
So 4000 again over 1.1 raised to 2 plus 4000 again over 1.1.
Raise that to the 3.
Now what we need to do is calculate that out and then subtract out 10,000 to see if it's actually worth it to invest.
Now let's go ahead and do that.
So I'm going to Change this to 4000 and we're going to go back in here, we're going to do a division and let's do this.
We're going to put a copy and paste.
Actually, I need to do a copy and paste formula.  There we go.
Well, it didn't paste it the way I wanted it to, so we'll do that.  Whatever.
A.  All right.
And then let's do this to the one, and then we're going to copy.
And I was changing the A's again, no big deal.
This will be A, A and 3.
So now I've got my three streams of payments right here.
You can see that my sum is $9,947.
So we have come back in here.
9,947, that's going to be something less than 1.
So no, because the amount that we get isn't enough in return.
So here, because the cash flow is not high enough.
All right, so we can clearly see again that the cash flow is not high enough.
So A is going to be our answer.
D does have the part of the answer being right.
But here the 12,000 doesn't account for the net present value formula that takes place.
That's why that is not the answer.
So we're going to go with A as our answer.
Let's move to this next question.
A project requires an upfront investment of 250,000 and returns 280,000 in one year.
If the firm's cost of capital is 15%, should it accept the project looking at a return here?
So we're going to look at how much I get in one year versus what the upfront investment was we have 280 minus 250 over 250 and I need to know what that is going to be.
So let me get my calculator here.
We're going to have, let's see, 30 divided by 250 and that is going to give me 12%.
So the return here is 12% over the course of one year.
But the cost of capital is 15%.
So in this case we wouldn't actually accept this project because the cost of capital is actually.  Read these here.
No, because the cost of capital should never be used.
Well.  Huh?
Oh nevermind.  The actual answer is C, not D.
I just happen to look for no.
See, I make a mistake every once in a while as well.
I look for no to begin with.
In fact, I should have kept on reading the actual question or the answer.
But C is the answer because the project here earns 12% and it's less than the cost of capital which is 15%.
So that's why C is our answer.
Let's move on to our next question.
Jackson's printing shop is the siding between printer X and printer yes.
All right, so printer X has fixed cost of $800 and marginal cost of 20 per unit.
So let's go ahead and write that in here we're going to have the cost of X is equal to 800 plus 20Q.
Printer Y has a fixed cost of 400 and a marginal cost of 40 per unit.
So CY and that's going to be 400 plus 40Q.
Now the question says at what output level would the total cost of using printer X equal the total cost of using printer Y?
So what we want to do is just set these two equal to each other and we're going to get 800 plus 20Q is equal to 400 plus 40Q.
And then we're going to solve this down.
So pull the 400 over.
So that's going to give us 400 left.
Pull the 20Q over to the other side and that gives us 20Q and then solve for Q.
So Q is going to equal 20.
So C is our answer.
Now what does this all mean?
This is our break even quantity when choosing between the two different technologies.
If we want to go above 20, then we would choose printer X because it has a lower marginal cost.
If we wanted to go below 20 then we would choose printer Y because it has a lower fixed cost.
So that's how you determine the which technology you're going to use.
Once you figure out what that break even quantity is, then you want to decide Do I want to produce more than 20 or do I want to produce less than that 20?
More than that break even quantity or less than that break even quantity.
Speaking of break even quantity, I knew this was going to be our next question.
We have fixed cost equal to $12,000.
Price is equal to $40.
I'm going to write this in here.
So fixed cost FC equal to $12,000.
Our price is equal to $40.
And let's just put some dollar signs in there.
And then our variable cost is equal to $20.
And it asks us what is the break even quantity.
Now, one thing to keep in mind when we talk about break even quantity, we talk about variable costs.
A lot of times you'll see an interchange of variable cost and marginal cost.
And that's completely fine, simply because in many contexts a variable cost can be your marginal cost, particularly if you have a linear variable cost.
That is I increase by one unit at each step, okay?
So that becomes my marginal cost.
So that's why we're going to look at it like this.
So let's set up our breakeven quantity here.
So QBR is standing for break even quantity.
And this is going to be equal to our fixed cost over our price minus our variable cost.
In this case, we could also put in marginal cost if we wanted to.
And let's go ahead and put in our numbers.
12,000 over 40 minus 20.
So that's 12,000 over 20.
And just going to rewrite that one more time.
12,000 over 20 and that is equal to 600 units.
So C equals is going to be our answer there.
All right, now let's move on to our next question.
Fixed cost is.
So this is another break even question.
But now we're doing break even price instead of quantity.
Let's just rewrite our breakeven quantity one more time.
So QBR before I do anything else, Fixed cost over price minus variable cost.
So what we're going to have to do is take the price and get it by itself.
Okay, so let's get our other information here.
Fixed cost is equal to 60,000.
Our variable cost is equal to 30, and our target quantity is going to be 2,000.
So let's just put these numbers in here.
2,000 is equal to 60,000 over P minus 30.
And I'm going to go in here and just do the math.
We're going to multiply both sides by p times or P minus 30.
All right, so this is going to give me 2,000.
P minus 30 is equal to 60,000.
So this is 2,000Pminus 60,000.
Something's going to be off here.
Actually.  No, nothing's going to be off.
Just me thinking something's going to be off because I'm just subtracting those 260,000 thousands.
Instead, we're going to get 2000p is equal to 120,000 and then divide both sides by P and we're going to get $60 as our price.
All right, so there we go.
Our break even price is $60.
We could easily confirm this by plugging it back into right there.
So we'd have 60,000 over 60 minus 30, which is going to be 60,000 divided by 30, which is 2,000.
So we can clearly see that our breakeven price is $60.
All right, let's move on to our last question.
Manufacturer customizes a $250,000 machine for a buyer.
After installation, the buyer threatens to renegotiate the contract at a lower price.
What contract feature could have prevented this?
Post investment holdup.
So here, post investment hold up, you want to look forward and reason back.
You think that the manufacturer or somebody in the contract is going to renege on the contract, they're going to do something different.
So what you want to do is foresee that's going to happen and then adjust the contract or other options so that it doesn't happen.
So let's look at the answers here.
Month to month contract, no penalties.
Well, that wouldn't even make sense.  No penalties.
So we're going to just go ahead and scratch that one out.
Multi year contract with enforceable purchase obligations.
Yeah, that is going to be our answer here.
You're putting them in a binding contract and you can enforce them to actually purchase what's taking place there.
Purchase the installation back from them, whatever.
A price that adjusts based on market rates, that actually wouldn't help the buyer there.
And then a flexible delivery schedule and quantity discount.
Again, that's not going to help either.
That allows the manufacturer there, excuse me, the buyer there, to change the change the terms.
It also allows the manufacturer to change the terms.
So in this case, this is why we want to go with B as our answer as it is aligning the incentives and protects the investment in place.
All right, that is it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.